boules kept podcast Freddie Gibbs is
here good friend of mine congratulations
on Alfredo sir yes I've been lucky to
have five or six of these songs in my
text messages for the last couple months
yep you were gonna release these a while
ago after the quarantine started you
were like man I'm gonna just drop these
and just [ __ ] people up yeah I mean you
know it was time you know I think that
uh I was you know I feel like I was
filling a void for what you know rap
kind of needed you know right now and I
think that I kind of was doing that with
bandanna
I've been doing this is a pinata you
know I mean I feel like I've been
carving out carving out carving I'm
carving out my own lane and now I feel
like I don't like you know kind of broke
the rule you know I mean like I never
ever had a billboard chart on radio none
of that so you know for this [ __ ] that
you know go top 20 on the Billboard off
of a album that I didn't even promote my
god you know say hey today album out you
know there's no like just kind of how
like you guys did the fede project it
just kind of felt like you know we don't
we're gonna drop this cuz our fans are
gonna our core fans are gonna love it
right and then it's successfully your
most successful project right correct
yeah yeah right now it's definitely my
most successful project you know to date
but I think that uh it wouldn't be
successful if you didn't have the
bandanas the pinatas the fatties you
know I mean Freddy You Only Live Twice
stuff like that you know I had to like
all that was you know like Michael
Jordan first seven years in the league
before he started winning championships
you know I compared today you know I had
to like get better take lumps you know I
mean and you know get physically
stronger as an emcee as a businessman
and all that and you know now we had
Alfredo well listen I think that you're
like you said pinata was kind of like
the beginning of like this run that I
feel like I mean you know me dude I've
been [ __ ] with you since oh nine the
first time you and I ever talked I was
on the radio in Boise Idaho in 2009 and
you called into my show
right and I've always said you're one of
the I mean you I did my top 50 list
neither guide you like 12 which people
gave me so much is it for but I'm like
doc you show me who can out rap Freddie
Gibbs please show me show me and I'll
[ __ ] I'll lower him down like
everybody's getting mad at me this week
for talking [ __ ] about your little Cool
J you know what I'm saying hey lil that
rap was trash as [ __ ] man I got to keep
it real listen so much for hip hop's
what are you a better rapper than LL
Cool J oh you might drink of course you
are way better listen look at it like
that one's got the Lakers look at it
like this yeah I must say it is I don't
wanna skip over there I'll ever know
because I'm not trying to disrespect lol
but never now I'm not disrespecting you
earlier I'm talking [ __ ] about you it's
a difference I talk [ __ ] about it I talk
[ __ ] about pule kill yes you do
that's my homie you know I'm sick so
don't take it personal you know what I'm
saying like but so it's like this man
like if it wasn't no lol it wouldn't be
you know me I wouldn't be saying
hundred-percent you know I'm saying but
you know at a certain point you know
your daddy gets see now and start
[ __ ] on itself and you know you got
it my [ __ ] tell them they delay make
it look you got to go this way bro you
know I'm saying like so you know I mean
with that said you know I mean you know
it'll certain you know I feel like this
man like I said without those guys
there's no me of course but but if you
take me you give me the DeLorean and
made me go back to they air the way I
rap now be real it's kind of like the
NBA conversation Bron in the 70s come on
man come on [ __ ] average set in 90
points a game and that's and that's like
no distance without that there's notice
so I can't diss it but I got it I got a
flair I got to let you know how much the
game has evolved exactly that's all its
evolution and you made that dumb ass
song with Brad Paisley I hear that's the
reason I started [ __ ] with you man
that actually did a racist [ __ ] my
[ __ ] dummy try and call you out for
this [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] I'm not
scared of you if you want to fight yeah
once house started doing like hey
everybody keep telling me they'll
swallow their but you know how many
swirlies the last album that I enjoyed
was goat and it was it was
it wasn't that great but IIIi I think he
had a song with ja Rule yeah yeah belong
that's less long I like I actually enjoy
a rule used to be tight as a kid who'd
be hating on ja Rule cuz 50 sitting on
like ja Rule and I love 50 cent to but
y'all had some hissing Tsar rule had
some [ __ ] - Charu strache now you know
what I mean and the Navy did fire fresh
little [ __ ] itself up you know I mean
[ __ ] like that but you know you did have
some great reference when you were a
great musical artist bro swear to God
you know I'm saying like there's
something I know about my friend
Frederick days when we drink things get
better come on brother
cheers to back-to-back albums of the
year now I don't know if Kendricks like
so by I don't know if Kendricks gonna
drop this year and put out his ill Matt
I don't know but we are in June of 2020
and you have the album of the year
that's my only competition I'll be
looking at it like Kendrick I'd be like
a sort of last like seven interviews all
my bad
leaves be asking like who rap but I
think was always want to add rappers
about rappers I [ __ ] like who's the
guy who kind of like I wouldn't say the
word scares you but like who's the guy
who you're like gonna scare me but I
look at him and I'll be like yeah he's
sharp you know I mean I want to be sharp
like that you know I mean he won't even
one of the only [ __ ] that I look at
like that him and like I said like black
thought I'd be like damn oh damn they
don't like doing songs of black yeah
I've actually once that black cloth wash
you in a record exactly that's why I had
to get him on a [ __ ] bed down
the shadow of a doubt that's why I had
to get on bandana and then you got him
back him back to reek so whatever you
want your rematch you get in it but the
respect you're the best you're the best
oh you're the best but whatever you want
to remand the respect for Kendrick like
talk about that because I feel like I
feel the same way Kendrick obviously is
one of the most commercially successful
chorus but he's also like just one of
those technical rappers ever of all time
so when you when you like Kendrick is
one of those guys who you because you're
one of those guys - there's a few of you
guys there's push the tee there's a few
of those guys not a lot there's not a
lot dude it's like four or five year old
it ain't that many Jedi as a disruption
there's a lot of you [ __ ] can't pull
out this
laser sword so yeah we like Kendrick is
kind of the guy who you're like okay got
like Kendrick I look at Kendrick push
I'll be like what and then they push
this hot judge a rapper I [ __ ] you
know if I buy into your character
first of all I gotta buy into your
character you know if I look at your
character and I think your character is
flaw and [ __ ] I mean I don't [ __ ]
with that
you know I'm saying being I look at the
N I look at your technical skill right
you know I mean your technical skill you
know you know that means a lot so I look
at guys like Kendrick and pushing even
Drake man Drake is one of the best I
mean I mean I don't got to say his name
because I don't got the chart the chart
speak for itself but but I don't die
from the like the chart [ __ ] I don't
know rap great you know I'm saying so
you know and I feel like you can't be
great in this [ __ ] unless like you like
no you got to study the game I look at
[ __ ] every time I look at everybody
you know matter like what what kind of
genre rap it is you know how you rapping
I look at my studying and I'd be like
man you know I mean damn like I got a
stay relevant you know saying because a
lot of [ __ ] you know I mean that's
not [ __ ] fall off I'll tweet it some
[ __ ] like we could all say it man the
key to this [ __ ] it's not falling off
and so all enough is the way you not
fall off is you remain a student of the
game at all times in anything that
you're doing whether it's [ __ ]
rapping and goddamn if you [ __ ] hope
in hope being pimpin without anything
need to remain a student of the game
because it's always something more that
you could learn if you closed your mind
off to learning that's when you [ __ ] up
you know saying I feel like me if you
stay learning being you always be great
you know I mean like broke my rep career
could have been over [ __ ] ten
years ago I mean let's be honest there
was point in times where you know like
I've never it could have been over a
long time no but how would you say there
was point times were like I just felt
like you just weren't like passionate
about this [ __ ] anymore
no that's what that could mean last year
I was gonna say it was about a year and
a half ago conversation we had but you
know what that mean when you were like
yo bandana my last out I do is so good
on board yeah sometimes I'd be like man
you know
you know me no cuz I remember I came to
your crib you played me bandana I rap
sometimes I feel like I'm playing it's
like me playing against you know some
[ __ ] four-year-olds and basketball
101 like Nick I'm okay you know this is
whatever you know I mean I just got a
brand new movie role like I'm trying to
you know branch out a blue [ __ ] listen I
want to know about the bass strip club
listen let me know if you need an invest
club Diego but let's get back to the
rapid I'm just talking to you um I'm
curious you're a big basketball guy yes
for calculate - I could play better than
Jake oh okay well listen I have no
comment on that because I can't play
better than I could comment on it I seen
you missed that dumb boy you can't play
better than me and white boy Matt you
definitely can't play better than me so
whenever y'all wanna do that ESG n
dreamville or whatever [ __ ] game I'll be
there I'll be the waterboy nah [ __ ] that
I heard it's Nicko's by the
[ __ ] star playing basketball
professionally hey Cole can hoop so what
I can't I can't whoo
you can't no but I can play
it's the difference I don't I could play
I can't I'm not no [ __ ] I'm not no hey
Kobe on that court with that with that
trainer in it no no no Hooper Rocco I
could play but I'm not no [ __ ] that
you know I like you know some [ __ ]
when you know they sleep with the
basketball you know I'm saying like
[ __ ] be I be whipping it up I don't got
time to sleep with the basketball
but I'm atletic Lee gifted enough to
play you know I mean you know if I gotta
compare myself to the NBA player my
basketball game is probably Patrick
Beverley shoutout the Lord shout the
Patrick Beverley I'll make it so you
won't you can't give it you have a
[ __ ] rough day that's why I say Cole
you can boot me none of you rap Nick you
know what the only [ __ ] that I feel
Kahoot me that [ __ ] me up on the court
gave me some buckets mama keep it real
all [ __ ] up that day
tossed hungover but even if I was a
foolish trophy still to [ __ ] me up the
best athlete in music the Michael Jordan
of athletics in music Chris Brown oh
yeah yeah what the [ __ ] wrong chart
[ __ ] yeah the [ __ ] did a month the
[ __ ] look man I seemed to make a plan
like three celebrity games a [ __ ]
[ __ ] shook like ten [ __ ] dr. Chris
Franken who here backflips athletically
good Chris Brown is the best athletic I
mean the best in Street
Hooper athlet he's the best industry
athlete out there and I dare any of you
[ __ ] to say anything otherwise because
they need Chris Brown that [ __ ]
can paint he could see you dance
dude that was out out - Chris Brown man
Sanz the Rihanna incident he's our
Michael Jackson
yeah dangun I all know nothing about
that he's our Michael Jackson he is like
Michael Jackson bro he is our Michael
give him his [ __ ] prop [ __ ] with that
[ __ ] [ __ ] I think he's the most
talented human being and he is one of
the most talented human beings on earth
he can do a whole mural on the side of
your house with a free-thinking I want
you to be on my album oh you know me so
I'm showing you some little bit how are
you Chris Brown rapping on your album
that's what I want I wanted a verse
listen you're a basketball guy I'm a
basketball guy if you had to assemble
your fantasy basketball starting five
line above MCS yes linen Kendrick at the
point I'm putting you at the - it's all
my rapping rapping okay because I need
okay we got Kendrick at the point
running point I got you at the - yes I'm
it's a to you at the - either the two
two three I'm like Jimmy Butler I'm
gonna die okay you go either way you
could lock up somebody yeah I need to
know who's filling out that small
forward power forward and center on the
squad best rappers in the game best
rappers in the game right now right now
we goin like no I'm talking about right
now right now like five to five is the
five best rappers in the game right now
Kendrick push pray Gibbs you're one yeah
I'm again we got three more names you
gotta fill out so we gotta push push is
one of them
Bruce is one mile hike so pushes is a
staple
Drake we tell my [ __ ] with just [ __ ]
with bars they say man I'm just waiting
for Drake to drop a classic album and I
think he might have one and take care
but I I agree what's up my [ __ ] with
bars right rank is on that level I just
I just off a bar he's there he's there
oh we guys we got we got one more mm-hmm
damn that's crazy to think about I'm
thinking about bar i'ma let you do two
more
get both of the six man in there oh we
thought we could throw the six man and
then [ __ ] okay if we go you know
I mean go one more [ __ ] with bars man
bro you summer right now right now right
now okay lead to wreak black dot that
[ __ ] get bars bro off the bench I'm
taking Roy the butcher Benny the butcher
or killer Mike yeah that's the right
there all those spots are in like
interchangeable okay are you just like
named like the best rappers all our best
rappers shout to kill the mic run the
Jews out right now you know Michel the
killer Mike man like killer Mike always
supported me I just thought I love
killing Mike like a brother I just text
you and told you I love you and you
ain't text me back I'm mad at you right
now kill him I want it I think I think
call me back [ __ ] I know you was
protesting and doing your killer Mike
[ __ ] already gives back I want to talk I
want to talk to you about the album I
just tweeted yesterday I was like you
know that like the last few weeks of
hip-hop
we got Alfredo and run Jules for like
right and I call it look kill the Mike I
call it you [ __ ] you ain't calling me
back man I don't like that [ __ ] like how
crazy is that like you know it's
interesting because I don't like that
[ __ ] kill them like you brought up any
of the butcher Westside gun just had
their Twitter and you know bullet good I
just talked to him yesterday yeah call
me right now he got an answer the phone
cuz I don't like this my guy Engle
answer cuz he he no answer right back he
no answer
cuz he's doing act of the act of this
activation he activating the streets he
got a barbershop
I'm saying swag shop the swag shop you
know as a bro heed me bro because look
kill the mic is that needle
killer my grant I'm rapping before it
before the run of jewels y'all don't
know about grants and rap game of course
I do
grind time come on bro y'all don't know
about that grant earn revenue yeah hey
you know he's the one who put pill on
cool I know you do
people money we own the [ __ ]
bootleg care podcast that [ __ ] was hard
I don't think he's answering her yeah
kill him Mike I told you he activating
he not ask God to kill her Mike though
cuz I set out to him I was in a position
a few last week where I was I didn't
know where donate money to you know I
wanted to make sure that my money which
is right place shouts all my
girlfriend's I love all y'all and daddy
is coming home soon
let me ask you something yes right now I
do feel like we're we have a there is a
class of hip-hop that has been missing
you've been consistent with what you do
correct and the people who I'm gonna
mention have been consistent with what
they do but I do feel like the last year
there's been a acknowledgement of the of
the of the culture of like yo there's
people are tired of the soundcloud
[ __ ] baris rap has been in a
horrible place bars a long time but what
I'm saying is there's Freddie Gibbs
there's Royce the five nine CyHi the
prynce s album was [ __ ] crazy
the crit is one of those guys like a Big
KRIT let me tell you something Big KRIT
get with me listen man Big Big KRIT a
night man big creepy one [ __ ] song
that's a that was a static select the
rest [ __ ] that was a static record
right no no no we did right let me tell
you the story about Rob me Anu oh wait
he was on that song without Ali's loop
it stop it by the way one of my favorite
I was very stressed song that was Big
KRIT song Big KRIT was like a man look
he hit me he was a hey man look man I
got this song man I was like what he was
like man you know the [ __ ] talking about
kind of like robbing and [ __ ] he was
like you know I feel like you like
robbing ass [ __ ] I feel like this [ __ ]
fits you more I said sentence him and
like an ink idea one of the best verses
of my life on the [ __ ] shot out
the big create great but but but but
come on family we supposed to Bing guy
back in the lab man I don't know what
you own and you know I'm saying but I
know gangster Caine you know I'm saying
we went on that one tour it I know
gangster Caine there's a lot to deal
with but I look this look Big KRIT I've
grown man Caine has evolved came and I
got kids now you know said
different [ __ ] see Big KRIT went on
tour Wow big big career with o2 or
Freddie Gibbs that didn't that wasn't a
family man where he went oh he's seen a
lot of [ __ ] so shout out the Big KRIT
man I always got a little for you man I
love you to death man you know I mean
whatever you doing I'm [ __ ] with it
but always supporting and always want to
[ __ ] they are the Dutch - that's money -
is my guy no big hits another one of the
goats yeah Big KRIT don't get him up
Chris [ __ ] your accolades [ __ ] your
record sales like if you don't think big
craze like one of the top 25 many said
the last 12 to 24 months worked on to
this Freddie Gibbs we're talking killer
Mike Royce and then there's the Griselda
squad I'm talking Freddie Gibbs
but what I wanted to talk to you about
okay okay yesterday Lambo tweeted when
he tweeted the two days ago correct yeah
he did the last two projects or do you
next it's dark and hos hot flesh of my
flesh blood of my blood no wait wait
what I gun is my boy and listen like yo
I'm huge result of fan and I mean III
think that what they've done is special
and I think that they're like when we're
having the discussion mm-hmm like the
good guys in rap and the elite in
hip-hop like those guys are in the
discussion you mentioned Benny the
butcher being one of your your you know
a dear friend of mine um and I think I
think I weighed dear friend of mine
Alfredo 1985 is a song of it obviously
the intro to the album it's actually my
favorite yes sir Bullock tabula akf
taken over the game we cracked him open
the 1942 for this cuz it's a celebration
man it's a bootleg careful taking over
today I also you know my dog my dog
I gotta be 100% honest with you bread
shot all my kids Fred can we be honest
here what's that I was a little sad that
you went to the LA leakers and and did
did that freestyle rabbit yeah I was a
little sad I did a freestyle you did but
it wasn't it wasn't that it wasn't as
good as that one
that [ __ ] was a endless a child to just
a child to milk but they share my heart
man it was that one was better than
yours I agree it was when I came in
yours I wasn't as prepared you weren't I
was kind of having a bad day but when I
went to noon he remembers Nico was I was
I wasn't ready I wasn't ready to rep but
when I got but I'm gonna keep it real
I'm a real name I gotta keep it real but
shook it off a rap it's like yo [ __ ] was
like flu game reps mm-hmm they it was
great they [ __ ] was like 69 point jordan
reps I just would like to point out that
there's been one radio DJ who's been
consistent in his support with you for
the last 11 years and it's boule Kevin
that's why I'm here that's my guy right
I don't even give a radio this is the
homie that's my brother right look
that's my dog for life so hey so next
time I'm gonna do a freestyle for you
and it's gonna be better than sour milk
and shoutouts army and they're good and
for the record I [ __ ] with both of those
guys not some weird over I hear the
radio beef I went up there what'd I tell
you earlier dawg
when I got an emesis of somebody to go
against I'm a better person so I so
that's why I like beef that's why I like
I don't give a [ __ ] if good [ __ ] like
me you know I'm saying because I like I
like the pressure I invited I love it I
love it
Ramba will probably mad I thought either
there's gonna be eating blah oh man this
[ __ ] got the Lambo you're the man I
Ralph you so [ __ ] a [ __ ] against you
cuz he against me but you know I'm
saying like bro like ah I invited so
that day come away when I went to the
[ __ ] saw milking him [ __ ] I
had my son and my baby mama was on some
[ __ ] I was like yo I gotta drop this
[ __ ] I got to go do some work she won't
answer on the phone she was wishing
sauce man you have to baby like [ __ ] it
that's a real mad rep so when you made
me mad
like I do best so I let [ __ ]
I'd be peaceful I'm doing my album and I
let somebody pissing me off and then I
finish it well it was amazing shouts of
milk shout to the other leakers that
first I was writing crazy Oh how's the
best freestyle that I'm gonna do another
one issue that's gonna be better than it
would be on my show you know what's
funny is I have like footage of a
freestyle we did on my birthday well you
were so drunk and it's probably better
than any other right was it you were
fate remember when we were in Vegas and
you came out to my birthday have
Rosenberg host yeah and you were you
brought some [ __ ] out from the [ __ ]
witch video shooting video I told my
first baby mama that I wasn't in Vegas
that day you just [ __ ] me up bro we
had Flyers Flyers but I laugh okay but
all that no more - I stopped going there
once I got all right no it's just crazy
because I have I watched I watched the
footage for my flip cam like a few
months ago and I was like damn this was
the drunkest Gibbs freestyle ever but
that being said you mentioned having
nemesis like and motivation I just got a
call from big booty ball hits movie see
bad I also you later I'm sure that's
like literally with the contact is she
bad I'm so did you find did you find her
in a smoothie shop no she only have no
hair in the ass yeah I'm a single man oh
I love it TRADD to my wife I love you
yeah anyway
shouts all to married [ __ ] I'm one I
mean I'm a married Caucasian I'm married
- are you into the game oh I see what
you did there
I'm a polygamist you know that Hey shots
of the Mormons shout-out to Janelle to
the private Jimmer Fredette you know I
went to save his day right
look the [ __ ] Farrakhan got up that he
was like yeah man all my wives in the
house I was like I want to live like
Farrakhan how many wives is very I don't
know who knows but he's the man yeah I
I'm a polygamous that's all that you
need to know and you're also a Muslim
yes sir but I just had some 42 so let me
ask you this how long have you been a
practice a practicing Muslim I mean you
know everybody practice you gotta
practice to get better hang on Sam but
how long has there's been a faith that
you followed I'm a vice Lord shot to the
Vice little shots of Chicago I'm vice
Lord before you I'm a man and in a vice
Lord and everything else after that
although I'm a man father and then Vice
Lords and everything else after so but
like cuz I'm an atheist so I'm not
somebody who's religious in any capacity
I feel you what I rock with our awkward
reviews I love everybody's views
represent what at what point in time did
you because I've seen you poach a
praying rug but you know and talk about
praying and all that like what point in
time did you commit to that faith oh I
think it wasn't always the case
when my grandfather died in like 2001
mm-hmm and like we was going to like um
Baptist Church our whole life not like
one of the reverend's there I'm gonna
say to make a name [ __ ] that [ __ ] his
name was pastor Davis you know I'm sayin
this is my father Gary a whole church
called new hope he's using my [ __ ]
past at New Hope the [ __ ] at my
granddaddy funeral like flirting with my
mom doing all kind of [ __ ] and like
[ __ ] came out about the [ __ ] afterwards
you know why I'm an atheist continued
bitch-ass [ __ ] exactly I feel you on
that so that and you know I mean and
they're like after that man you know
when I start hanging around a lot of
like the older like Lords like um no
love shopping no love you know I mean a
lot of people don't know no but he like
you know vice Lord this in Chicago area
is in Gary big homie got another but
like guys like that like showed me the
Islamic doctrine within life you know I
mean so I seen that in and I was like
you know the no pork you know I mean in
a like my [ __ ] you know I got gun
charters in you know when you go to the
county you
dick Lord since I'm like that specially
like oh look at you you [ __ ] up older
older guys and stuff like that you know
they teach you things you know I mean so
I just you know kept you know kind of
you know following that and living
better as I sit and drink 1942 I think a
lot of people that are watching the
interview get a lot of people watching
they never you don't know what the Vice
Lords are cuz they're not from the
Midwest they don't need to know what we
are we're silent so you're secretly
nothing what is the voice of I don't
know that is yeah that's crazy
we talked about the last couple years
mmm-hmm 1985 the intro to the album yeah
it's probably my favorite instrumental
in the album shout out the white life
all of the ales and I'm saying hustle
all the folds I'm sorry I just said okay
that was 1985 the last record recorded
cuz obviously has a lot of the last
dance references in it um idea in 1985
while I was watching the last dance
last dance episode eight while all the
rest of the audience watching episode
two just a few weeks ago by the way cuz
I had all this [ __ ] before all y'all it
didn't leak shout out the Katie saw the
Kevin Durant I saw Katie entry creep
we're gonna talk about your relationship
with Katie as a basketball fan I have a
very unfavorable opinion on Katie but
I'd regret I do recognize let's tell
about that
I do recognize he we just talk
basketball listen Gibbs I recognize they
get that Katie's been a big supporter of
yours for a long so it gets my pass
shut the Katie man Katie is like ma you
know that's like one of my brothers man
I love he's been a big supporter Meyer
him like give him you know you can't
give a [ __ ] with 600 million all of the
advice but you could you could be like
bro you know I mean it's love man I just
try to just you know just provider you
know just know to homey vibe I [ __ ] with
homie and you know we watch basketball
talk about life that's it like we really
you know that's that's that's Amari home
you know I know a lot of needles they
play basketball and a lot of
that who a lot of [ __ ] in the NFL I
know some [ __ ] that [ __ ] play
tennis I love some soccer meters you
know I'm saying I'm but like you know
kappamini like having me and Kevin is my
real friend I [ __ ] he's been a big
supporter of yours for a long time
shoutout to my [ __ ] that's my dog with
that being said what are your thoughts
on his move with the Warriors what do
you mean I'm just curious because from
I'm a strictly basketball perspective
here you know I'm Parliament partial I'm
partial bro so anything that unbiased
perspective here I'm biased I mean you
are are you saying anything that bro
dude our support okay so anything when
he did that [ __ ]
I was already I was supporting it
anything he wanted to do you know I
support it and you know I mean like I
think that you know you can know
somebody from a fan standpoint when you
know them on a personal standpoint it's
different everything is different you
know I mean like Birla you you know you
could have looking at things different
you see things different you know I mean
like and I don't like having friends and
stuff that I can't learn from and build
from because like I just told you like
when you stopped being a student in the
game that's when you [ __ ] up yeah you
know I'm a student of life so you know
you my friend I learned [ __ ] from you
every time I come around you we just
talk about dick pills if you're in the
LA area and you need viagra I got the
hundred milligrams get at me and then
wrong with it listen it ain't a lot of
people to let you know how good of
friends we are
exactly cuz we could talk today a lot of
people that I call Michael oh you one of
my close friends kid yeah you know I'm
saying like you know Katie that's a
close friend of mine so you know I'll
learn it when I go around homies and
I'll learn from them you know I mean you
know a vice versa you know me so you
know I don't I don't really [ __ ]
nobody that can't suck no gamer from you
know I mean and we both soaked up game
from each other you know me and you me
and Katie all my [ __ ] that I [ __ ] with
Kevin's exact couple of Kevin's shoutout
to KD shut up Katie I hope I meet him
one day and and I take a photo with him
so all my friend the [ __ ]
[ __ ] last couple of
championships without him anyway neither
side they wouldn't have he'll [ __ ]
knows beyond office say all that
[ __ ] let's put it into that debate
let's put it into that [ __ ] [ __ ] because
the [ __ ] I can see if he went there and
he was just a piece no no no no damn
went there and became Finals MVP in two
times in a row
so I'd like to point out that the
Warriors were number one championship
number one had KD or I'm sorry had Kyrie
and Kevin Love been injured the whole
series LeBron still took him by himself
to six with dalla dov'è I'm talking
about year one before Katie each other
LeBron to LeBron is on my Mount Rushmore
basketball 100% but what I'm saying is
well I think about think about think
about that I love that but think about
the Warriors can we stop go ahead the
lebra MJ shoot I mean I think it's I
think whoever says after last day how
about this after the last dance can we
stop the lebra MJ [ __ ] know what I'm not
why can't we listen if I ask somebody
who's the goat if your answer isn't
either Michael Jordan or LeBron then I
need it then I'm like yo what the [ __ ]
is wrong with you you do because I do
think like God rest Kobe soul right like
I think there's people who I speak with
or like it's Kobe and I'm like well fam
you're just not a basketball fan then
you're like no bro no you could put Kobe
up but you can't put I just think that
there's it's like there's Jordan and
LeBron bro let me tell you it's six
[ __ ] okay yeah you can be like yo this
[ __ ] was the greatest player of all
time oh you're six
this is six [ __ ] then you can be like
yo this [ __ ] the greatest player of
because to me it's only track record no
it's not only two because I'm not we're
not in the same peer group of our
fathers you know I'm saying so them
[ __ ] might think we'll Chamberlain or
bill Russell's the greatest of all time
which also goes back to the rap
conversation zactly that we just had
about exactly yo ride back then
bro that's why so much basketball [ __ ]
in my lyrics cuz I compare raps of
basketballs
you know I'm saying so bro if you want
to think about the six greatest layers
who's the six bro LeBron for show Jordan
of course Jordan is the greatest player
of all time on and off
court let's get that understood okay on
and off the court
Jordan is the greatest player of all
time LeBron you know I'm saying Larry
Bird is the greatest [ __ ] white boy
that's such a basketball I don't
disagree of all time I do not disagree
he is the greatest Luca - is on his way
Lucas about bro ten years ago talk about
Luke listen ask the man you heard here
first with him tell me Lucas I am a big
Luca guy he's gonna be go nuns and magic
yeah cream cream one more [ __ ]
Kobe Oh two more [ __ ] Kobe Tim Duncan
no Kevin Durant you could do that Kevin
Durant is one of the and I'm not saying
that [ __ ] I was saying he's not a singer
my friend who can seize an automatic
[ __ ] book I think Kevin Durant's top
two or three score ever he's the top two
score ever first of all I think he's one
of the greatest Michael Jordan in Canada
render the best who scores any and if
I'm being honest again I gotta go then I
gotta go to James hard listen and you
saying that I can't even disagree with
the harden point but do I put Katie over
Tim Duncan I do got five rings
I don't put sometimes about rings bro
I am on there's a lot of [ __ ] that
ain't about rings this is not Tim Duncan
the greatest power for Danny with
Charles Barkley above [ __ ]
Stacey King Stacey King got three
reasons or two or three rings
I don't disagree Robert oh he's got ring
Thank You money no if we're talking
rings bill Russell's would go thank you
if I don't disagree but you would put
Katie over Tim Duncan yes if you picking
a [ __ ] team and in the last two
[ __ ] left and I got a note I know I'm
magic Duncan is the best power forward
of all time if I got magic at the point
but I don't need them this is Jordan MW
is the best power forward of all time
but I don't need him in my starting a
fight I got a Kevin Durant
I don't need you never man if I got Shaq
and Kevin Durant I don't need you you
know we do agree on the Shaq point
obviously go I think I think pink like I
said I'll put KB at the phone and then
you tell me I'll do it at [ __ ] you want
to take Shaq it's better than any Center
ever peak Shaq you take if you push a
cup against will or [ __ ] Bill Russell
listen it's a road respect to will or
Bill Russell but [ __ ] y'all the only
sinners that I see for real the best
sinners to me Shaq in a king I love Bill
Russell and we'll talk about Ariadne go
get better
cut it out y'all's plan means Bob Cousy
you're playing against people look like
Nike you think it's nickel a blue look
here I would have dunked on blue that
cave all day I don't disagree
so look [ __ ] Hakeem Olajuwon
yeah yeah
Hakeem Olajuwon is the best skilled
center of all time I don't disagree and
yo of all time back-to-back imageshack
is is one in 1/8
I don't disagree they are one in one
that might be you and me as age group
and I don't disagree with you I don't
give a [ __ ] about age group those are
the best [ __ ] of all time you
put you know I go off put me in any era
put a check in their era put her came in
in the air put a keema in the era he's
going disagree you can't put little
Russell in any era I don't care what you
say
he morning in chat no disrespect to Bill
Russell but you can't put Bill Russell
in any era and he was the see if you put
if you put bill back in any errors over
he's the sees if you put bill run if you
put Kevin Durant any era Gibbs piece of
see listen if you put Bill Russell
seduce in defense you came to fear seven
feet right three if you put Bill Russell
against Dwight Howard it's over
come on and Dwight Howard the white our
white Howard was physically more
dominant he had a booty injury pause
listen but he brought up but
la you know we like the right now
Kobe didn't [ __ ] with him back in the
day but we like him now hey Kobe in deaf
[ __ ] with Dwight so he like okay I we
cooled why you got the purple hair let
me ask you this we're gonna now Fredo
working on bandana and pinata what is
the how was the creative process
difference different between you working
exclusively with mad lib and you working
exclusively with out on a project how do
we get off basketball I mean cuz you
know we talked about this raps okay [ __ ]
the rap okay look Alchemist and Otis I
hold them in the same regard 100% elites
the e leads like way top level top-shelf
elite 1942 classy it's like if we had
some classy azu right here or some
patron yep no or some [ __ ] what I'm
sorry I what's wrong oh no [ __ ] stop
stop Bullock if if we had this and if we
had a bottle of Casa Azul next to it
that's that's how mass malov and
alchemist to me for the alcoholics this
should be an easy reference to
understand I'll commence the only [ __ ]
The Alchemist you know I mean look at
when he make this man live and the only
[ __ ] that Madlib looking when you make
a beast is alchemist so listen bro both
of these guys are my [ __ ] great
friends so I got the bet I got something
that no rapper ending name guy no these
are my god these are my friends you know
Sam and [ __ ] [ __ ] asked me today my
Ebro shotty bro a focal you'll play my
songs 107 but but you know what it's hot
97 but I love you Rosenberg glaze them
shout out to Rosenberg late night but
Ebro you own play gangsta came but you
need to because the game is about the
switch and then you go yeah okay and
what I'm telling you first I love you
anyway music anyway shut up music hi 97
autumny
everything you represent here offers a
great guy cuz I [ __ ] with you you know
why cuz I photos you as you feel good
you were activists first 100% you my
[ __ ]
but mostly talking about Ebru alchemist
we remember alchemist first Madlib yes
okay so me votes tomorrow Alchemist
first [ __ ] man live and both of
these [ __ ] are top echelon
producers done hundred percent so I mean
we're time of these great
so the fact I will contribute I would
you know should be the fact that you
know my rapid kill got better from going
to rap school with these two guys that's
fact
I feel like a lot of [ __ ] need to go
to rap school a lot of [ __ ] don't know
how to rap you know what I mean and
listen how come if you if you in a
studio it out and malya bro you're gonna
[ __ ] become a better [ __ ] rapper
dog go to rap school everybody that come
to Alchemist to do
I'd be like broke-ass al I told him
mister I said bro it's rap school this
is rap school right here I'm saying like
bro and it man live don't even come out
so if you get the [ __ ] chance the
glimpse the the opportunity the the mini
window of getting remarried [ __ ] that's
a blessing you know I'm saying so like
both of those guys are a blessing to the
game man I love those are my two
favorite producers you know saying I
love everybody you know saying but those
guys sharpened me up they sharpen my
sword they made me a better rapper like
I can't
I wouldn't that I [ __ ] come on bro I'm
out I'm out this [ __ ] [ __ ]
hold pushing Lamborghinis [ __ ]
Porsches I got a Aston Martin outside
right now I was had none of that [ __ ] if
it was not for malli Alchemist because
these are the guys that pushed me to
better be a better rapper these other
guys that sharpen my sword you know I'm
saying so then when I get on any other
producer Pete any other producer be
obliterated cheers cheers to that
Gibbs you and Madeline I know I know
Lambo had a lot to do with you guys
getting together please
this was 2014 great this happened yeah
talk about cuz look at the end of the
day like I feel like you have quite
barely made it out to be neither
butchart an ATAR
by the way Tana talks [ __ ] incredible
chakras on fire I need a butcher
shoutout to come that I went at a
butcher you money listen um I that era
of your career mmm-hmm 2014 mmm there's
barely made it there's es GN Baby Face
Killa right there's there's like the
post GZ [ __ ] mm-hmm
this record drops and it to me kind of
proved what I've been telling everybody
this whole time because I feel like
throughout your career early on like
yeah
like bro straight killer straight killer
no filler like all this [ __ ] like even
even the [ __ ] that you were doing on
what would GZ the Run DMC [ __ ] all this
[ __ ] like like yo I would send people
back then like yo my man just jumped on
a record with Jeezy and he's also doing
a record with Dom Kennedy like [ __ ] out
of here
right correct but you dropped this you
thought Don Kennedy you dropped [ __ ]
cocaine pinata mm-hmm what's technically
was pinata right cocaine it was supposed
to be cocaine pinata but I think he came
out as just pinata I got some dope in
the pinata to a person and then I named
album a today that was real true what
I'm saying is I got the Lambo that was
2014 you and Madlib come together from a
rapper like from a fan's perspective I
saw it is like this [ __ ] is about to be
crazy part is I didn't know who I didn't
know at Brahma I didn't know who the
[ __ ] no I not know you at the time so I
knew you didn't know about that world I
didn't know about that world so I knew
about I knew who Malley was that I knew
who the alcoholics was at that shot to
the licks shot early shots attack -
[ __ ] King T I'm gonna keep it with
you I think I talked to Tash and or
around that time and the thing that
really inspired bad dinner I mean I bet
down opinion I'm sorry don't be never
really inspired me working with Matt
live is like I said she broke I'm a real
competitive [ __ ] sometimes it ain't no
disrespect I'm under that [ __ ]
I'm saying like I was hanging around
blood Mitchie slit Chama she slipped San
Diego chopping me slip me a Mickey
that's my big homie yeah we know we do
you know but strong arm steady exactly
that right there I see who's just maybe
I did happen with was this they did exam
on an amazing album Rhonda fill that
agony go to agony exactly yeah so listen
I'm like this how I learned my little
cuz Lambo could bring me [ __ ] all day
but like yeah yeah this is great
you know I love Lambo that's my dog
you know me but the fact that we
brothers and we can disagree Andrea Gris
that's what makes us that's what makes
our dynamic he bring me shouldn't I be
like ah I'll bring him shitty but uh you
know I'm saying like the fact that we
can tell each other the truth is what
makes our alliance so great you know I'm
saying so because if we tell each other
the [ __ ] truth at all times when they
come to like the artistic [ __ ] then it's
alright it's like crack they're good she
gonna float to the top
feel me the crack will flow to the top
you scoop that out you feel it was in so
like I didn't know about
Otis like that I know a little bit but
then I was like I but I was hanging
around Mitchie you know me because I
[ __ ] with mint you sleep that's my MC
that's my big bro I was hanging around
Mitchie and I was impressed with what he
was doing and I was impressed with
crying I wasn't I was hanging around
crying I was him around crying I cuz we
was all doing drugs facts he was super
sir shout out to the whole shout out
strong artists are the crime now of
course lightning at that point me and
crime was my [ __ ] uh drinking uh
Ocean Spray activists and he knows
that's why I owe you guys same in Ocean
Spray karana I put me on or spray that's
why senator [ __ ] on was a cataracts
I said cry mix with Craig and grape I
want to see what that about cuz I was
drinking the [ __ ] with sprite I was in
the future and [ __ ] like oh yeah dirty
sprite but we're trying to I was like
evening look I mean I got this
cran-grape Ocean Spray I said damn and
be the Chicago kid you know saying we
was all in that culture shadow DJ
legendary Gibbs collaborative person
legendary doesn't we got you guys have
any I agree that is my brother
I love BJ you are a legend I love you a
lot of [ __ ] don't give you your
flowers but I always give you flowers
because I love you dog and you and DJ
got real class I'd die for BJ BJ got
real classics some of the greatest
rappers of all time
BJ a classy by self a hundred percent
shout - BJ each other BJ you my brother
I'll owe you - Dada fee I killed killing
and go view I was shooting into 25 times
in the face for you but back to the Iraq
or back to the mad lib [ __ ] so you
obviously you're friends with Michie
you're friends with which cron done
friends a crime so I see Stoney Jackson
I'm like damn I can make something like
that I could do that [ __ ] too you know
I'm Sam mmm if y'all give me opportunity
to do that [ __ ] - I can do it actually -
you know I mean like Lambo always you
know that both [ __ ] with stones throw
stones throw just don't throw no you
know I mean that was a part of that era
Madlib stone's throw call that whole
indeed [ __ ] backpack [ __ ] saw the
Eagle hunter personally you know he
gotta put this [ __ ] together you know
I'm saying I got your prostate with his
lab boy he got our relationship made the
[ __ ] pinata me and Mary they
didn't know each other dog yeah let's be
real we a mad lib didn't know each other
until we made that until we start until
we started making out it was like well
[ __ ]
he was like you great ass [ __ ] rapper
I said damn you a great ass [ __ ]
producer [ __ ] I'm saying
and now the relationship to meet him got
his brothers big brother little brother
you know I'm saying like bro Pro I was a
die for madly I'll lay my life down for
him now you know I'm saying because we
we make some great [ __ ] bro you know and
like now like we're we're at a point
where we didn't tour together we didn't
bid through the war together we do went
to the war with the [ __ ] major
labels together you know I'm saying
so like Madlib is a look at him is the
same way I look at how come his bro a
big brother you know I mean like these
guys are guys that shaped my career
without these guys I wouldn't have a
[ __ ] career like [ __ ] my daughter go
to [ __ ] Sierra Canyon [ __ ] you
know what's up [ __ ] [ __ ] cost
[ __ ] I can't pay for this [ __ ] if I
have [ __ ] how can this matter
if I'm not on real goddamn radio blue
they keep you on the radio so you know
I'm not a [ __ ] radio bro I'm not
gonna radio bro I'm aware you know I'm
saying so I make my millions off the
radio you know I mean I made my millions
by [ __ ] with real [ __ ] I make my
millions my [ __ ] way
alchemy is my [ __ ] with man these are my
these are my Big Brother's what is been
the big difference creatively between
alchemists and mad lib when it ain't no
[ __ ] difference so there is no time
somewhat like when you approach these
albums what is the different cuz I mean
we hear about Madeleine being a guy who
makes records on his iPad meow
okay I'm gonna tell you difference does
the obvious they're different producers
let's say a difference I'll tell you
difference okay
ain't a difference but we all a family
huh
we all the family we all are mafia me
alchemist madly we are all a [ __ ]
mafia you know saying you're all the
[ __ ] family you can't have one
without the other
Otis I told you [ __ ] on Fetty I said
colder than anything you ever heard on
al all this [ __ ] cuz Alchemist is family
with Otis Otis
Alchemist and all his family with a
million percent exactly so we all really
really all one thing and we're showing
y'all what we can do you know I'm saying
I'm really all one thing if me Otis and
I was in the room together right now
yeah every [ __ ] will marvel at that I
don't disagree at least anyone who has
really ever him thank you exactly and
I'm Sam but me and Otis don't make [ __ ]
without when I made bad Nana I hit al I
said bro you like this you know saying
yeah when I made [ __ ] Alfredo
I said hey al you like this because we
all a [ __ ] intertwined family al
oldest oh no all the Sara oh no we we
are [ __ ] family we family we like
related we blood family bro alchemist
[ __ ] oldest oh we we all Lambo oh no
we all the [ __ ] family broke so we
move like a [ __ ] off your dog
like we don't give a [ __ ] about I don't
give a [ __ ] about who like my [ __ ] yeah
I don't care about I stop giving the
[ __ ] who like my [ __ ] ten years ago row
you know when I gave a [ __ ] who like my
[ __ ] when I gave a [ __ ] about who like
my [ __ ] when I was signing in Jeezy I
was like damn man I wonder if people
liked it because he was always about
that I don't give a [ __ ] if you like my
music my [ __ ] like [ __ ] once I got
rich I stopped giving the [ __ ] let me
ask you did an off the top off the top
and I mean that once I got broke Lambo
just called me this week well that was
about three weeks ago and he bought a
brand new house bro
you know I'm saying so it's like bro all
my people and my family around me is
doing good you know me so I don't really
give a [ __ ] about nothing else that's
all I give a [ __ ] about how big we
talked about this before we started the
podcast talk about the motivation that
you've that fueled you from disbanding
from CTE correct because I'm Jeezy
he's a motivation every day
because I look up to young jeezy I
didn't start listening man or a rope
come on bro 2010 I could have [ __ ] with
any rapper [ __ ] I could have [ __ ]
with Yo Gotti Rick Ross anybody I love
me I do I remember I looked at the autos
[ __ ] I was there I'm saying but I
really live up to Young Jeezy and I was
like you know me I look up to him so
that said you know every all the music
that I make after that mm-hmm it's to
you know to prove [ __ ] wrong to food
that I was where I was supposed to be
you know I'm saying so you know that
little bit of motivation like you know
it gives me a you know give me that push
you know I'm saying so I you know every
day every time I go on the move every
project I make I'm trying to prove
somebody you're wrong and I'm saying I'm
from Gary Indiana bro and I'm the all
the [ __ ] rapper from there
[ __ ] City
yeah and that [ __ ] is no [ __ ] once it
is that [ __ ] ain't no coincidence Harvey
so it's it's like this because I got a
different mentality than a lot of [ __ ]
you know I'm saying I'll take the
adversity and I use this [ __ ] fuel you
know I'm saying a lot of people don't do
that comes in and the fact that I can do
that you know puts me above a lot of
[ __ ] you know I'm saying like bro I
wasn't supposed to make in 2006
Interscope drop me I remember
no I'm saying although I wasn't supposed
to be where I'm at right now and your
longevity is because child to Just Blaze
for all the unapproved beats that
released it right I'm just saying though
like like you know I'm not supposed to
be where I'm at right now but I'm here
because you know I mean pure
perseverance and Lambo I mean you got a
Lambo I always tell you this I'm like
dude you like there were times where it
would have been easy for you to make the
industry move and to like not piss off
whoever you pissed all correct but
you're you are who you are and you never
compromise that and like even if it
meant you you know burn it like who
gives like you I'm Fred
so like take me as I am or go [ __ ]
yourself correct and you know what I'm
gonna keep it real - bro
you know I would have had that same
mentality if Ida had Ghazi trying to
Empire
Gazi everybody else could say what they
want to say you know I mean but you know
Ghazi made me rich you know I'm saying
like Ozzy Nemo and I mean like they got
the hotel man here those guys like that
they made me like you know they made me
be able to buy a home I wouldn't be able
to buy a home without Ghazi or Nima
you know I mean I wouldn't be able to be
in position and take care of my family
without Ghazi anymore hell of a house so
I always give no props to those guys
they gave me the confidence they taught
they showed me that I can be a
businessman outside of the music
industry you know I mean like I didn't
have to bow down you know I mean that's
why I always give love to Gaza because
Ghazi always showed me that and I have
to bow down you know I mean I can do
what the [ __ ] I want to do like bro lie
bro this out of me Oh
RCA just out man on my [ __ ]
like the label she's on [ __ ] Empire
yeah
streaming saying like real [ __ ] dawg
like I love Nima like a brother you know
me I love Ghazi like a brother tax so
you know I mean you know you know
bandana that [ __ ] was like you know 21
but this is like you know top 20 in the
Billboard bro you know I'm saying so bro
like you know me and Lambo you know we
really had a plan for this and you know
sometimes it be too many [ __ ]
cooks in the kitchen you know I'm saying
this it's crazy that this is doing
better than banana and this ain't even
on a [ __ ] abanazar CA bro and I
was hoping that I let you know right but
in the Grammy nominee lon I'll talk
about that but I mean it same
time of course you give yeah I mean
that's our job to do a little [ __ ] like
that
of course I got some of I just sex I
care about I don't care about gets nub
right before it it before the snub it
was other [ __ ] me and you had the convo
we were like yo this RCA thing works out
it'll be because you got the Grammy
nomination because this album is Grammy
worthy I remember you and me talked and
we went through all the albums I'm like
yo there's no way this did and then some
you know like shelter 21 savage no doubt
that shot you know like 20 what Savage
should not have been nominated for album
of the year hip hop over your [ __ ] like
that album but it was a good album shout
out the Peter edge man you know I'm
saying other Peter is and you know the
people that are CA you know gonna be
able cuz you know they did they [ __ ]
job you know I mean it's other people
that you know RCA like higher than [ __ ]
that didn't do what the [ __ ] there's
person you know I'm saying like them
[ __ ] them [ __ ] that be trying to
hack I like all on that old brothers
[ __ ]
yeah brother [ __ ] I brought that
[ __ ] pin that bandana [ __ ] over
there finished product you know I'm
saying so let's let's let's put that
[ __ ] out there though from a game maybe
I'm a year and a half working listen
i'ma tell you this money like the
bandana [ __ ] that worked on bandana
was Freddie Gibbs Lambo he gone
and my [ __ ] madly that's it anybody
else to try to act like they worked on
bandana we're going game from Adana
they ain't do [ __ ] you know I mean
shoutout to my [ __ ] Josh blooms I'll
[ __ ] show you my dog off tips to my
homeboy Jerry let's jump ahead again it
for Alfredo anybody else is a [ __ ] you
and Rick Ross interesting history not in
the sense that you have any sort of beef
with Ross but there's a point in time
where CTE and MMG had issues correct
you've called out your bands all of the
pitbull putting all the dog put over 600
bands I did that I do that you hold you
took shots at Waialae you to try to meek
south or Wally that's what I'm saying
like during that time where you were
with CTE you were the guy who was like
if there's gonna be some smoke I'm here
I'm [ __ ] I'm the smoker a hundred
percent I am I know that there was any
clique let me click on me and I was
infamous story enforcer what I tell you
I'm gonna patrick beverley infamous
stories of what award show was at where
gunplay was there and there was a some
backstage action wasn't there something
to happen backstage at one of the award
shows that you were around and you were
like um no no no but I wasn't there
I think Jeezy and them [ __ ] got beat
up by some [ __ ] but I wasn't there
I didn't do that so Ross is on this
record and me and you've always said
like yo I'm a fan of Ross Ross is
[ __ ] incredible always giving it up
to Ross always was there like a elephant
in the room discussion with you and Ross
like about that era like yo or was it
just like you know I [ __ ] with yous
never it was like I [ __ ] what you got
[ __ ] with you it was love it was always
love you know saying like you know that
error is that ever and you know what
like come on man
cheers cheers bro Young Jeezy is
musically irrelevant just be real dawg
you know man be real did you this says
that sobbing oh you [ __ ] did it I
mean I love I'd like to comment on it
well we don't know question I don't
wanna be here legend listen a legend I
will say this but right now you're you
asked me a question and what you want to
do you want to fight you don't want that
listen I love you I understand that you
feel you but you know you can't let me
speak fight me
you can't I'll rat me I mean you think
it I can't beat me up I'll rat me I
don't really give a [ __ ] of bread let me
get some what a four thread listen Fred
I'm here to speak and Lambo look you you
refugees are you gonna invite me to her
cuz they [ __ ] be ducking me do you
remember when you and when you were in
Vegas and it was me you and Jeezy on the
same interview I think it's the only
time you guys did an interview together
on YouTube we was yeah station know you
guys were together what it's remember
when you guys had to show up the pearl
and then me yeah me you and your girl we
went across the street made a [ __ ]
[ __ ] teach you I don't remember we did
Cheers
but with that being said Jeezy you are a
legend with that being said nah
a fan of your last album if anything I
gave it I gave it a real go last hour my
enjoy to Jesus was TM 103 bro your last
three she's been that well that being
said you and Ross getting together on a
record that's that's big especially for
someone Ralston Atlas song with him in
Ross on Ross lastly I'm as hard as foot
for sure - it was hard to be bluffing
they'll bomb two days ago
listen bro I'm not a hater of music so
get me wrong oh no you're not gonna need
to make great music out of the head
that's hard
I don't give a [ __ ] no member like have
you and GZ had any sort of conversation
since everything happened any sort of
correspondence I tried you know I mean I
try to be a ruining than the really like
you know because we have people who
obviously 211 was a part of that
situation that's my brother
211 shoutouts had a [ __ ] a
level up store [ __ ] me go buy some
clothes go buy anything that do selling
you [ __ ] whether it's clothes or
anything shot up the Dukes that's my
[ __ ] to eat 11 need to shout out the
[ __ ] that's my [ __ ] you know I
mean but I figured oh yeah what I was
gonna say was like was there ever any
sort of dialogue that like you know I
definitely ran through you know I mean
you know I've been like like I said I
got love for film you know I mean and
all in trapper die and all of that [ __ ]
you know I mean that [ __ ] was like you
know some of the like you know things
are like kept me rapping and [ __ ] like
that so you know but that's any time you
know we ain't never liked me in deuce
i'ma keep it real with you
when I met that [ __ ] tweeted every
night he like that [ __ ] yeah and that's
because we was two of the same kind of
needed he's both like [ __ ] you [ __ ]
[ __ ] you so me in 211 and we ain't like
I ain't like that [ __ ] when I first met
that [ __ ] yes part of the same CT air
right CT era I like that [ __ ] when I
first met that [ __ ] I was like [ __ ] you
when he was like me to [ __ ] you right
but that like now [ __ ]
if I die I'll leave my kids are 211
you know I'm saying like 211 is my
brother I love anything I lay my life
down on train tracks for the new year
you know I'm saying if that's my brother
you know saying but at first you know it
was the environment where we you know
was both like almost like you guys were
brought in the same kind of body to do
the same thing yeah you know I'm saying
the beat the street [ __ ] the label and
like be you know and rap I'm saying but
like you know once we like got with each
other and got and figured each other out
man we we brothers dog like bro out this
[ __ ] will go to here he sleep in my
house you know I'm saying like for real
though this is my brother for real like
it ain't a lot of like [ __ ] that I got
it like it's like a rat friends and I
don't look at that [ __ ] a rat friend
you know I mean like that's my bro
like 211 is my brother like I love
that's a great thing that came out of
the GZ [ __ ] with me mean 211 mean boy
clearly were to 11 and me like to let
like bro like that is worth more than
meaning a billion dollars I mean his
relationship you know I mean I mean his
camaraderie like robbing living at Lake
over 15 years you know I'm saying so
like being being close to a real [ __ ]
like that I mean a lot to me I look like
I said I'll lay my life down for a
[ __ ] like that I love squeal Evan you
know I'm saying like [ __ ] we're going
like [ __ ] the [ __ ] all that
CTE [ __ ] you know I'm saying like me and
this thing gonna been through real [ __ ]
together you know saying so like that's
why I say like bro I couldn't call that
guy my brother like I don't I'm [ __ ]
all right [ __ ] that rap [ __ ] all that I
should yeah like me that I will smoke
you about 211 and two that won't smoke
you about me that's it I talked to Royce
right after his album dropped and he
specifically called you out he was like
you guys set a record he said he said he
said it's on YouTube don't remember but
essentially he definitely acknowledged
like cuz I was like yo man I need to
hear you and Fred on some [ __ ] and he
was like dude tell Fred I'm here like
I'm ready
you and Royce
two of the jedis yes the Jedi 100% the
definitely do Jetta as Royce candidate
[ __ ]
he definitely attend that but like I
taught the Royce last week I was coming
only [ __ ] you guys got to do a record
together we've been over dude it's
[ __ ] rare Royce in my eyes you want
the best rappers all time ever and I'm
ready
so already told you I just coming to
Instagram post so Royce whenever you
ready I'm ready
you know I mean like I'm working on my
new album so you want to get on that
let's do it race is a Jedi I know you
working with I know you always working
on the album so like I mean it's heart
like Royce is like come on Detroit if I
go to Detroit I'm a car race let me know
that he know that he know that we hit I
call Royce one time you know I'm saying
when I got the Detroit and Tim most of
those [ __ ] awesome look dope boy then
they discover they spray paint on my
tour bus you know they're not in the red
think they were on CTA of course they're
not in Revit you know what gives
there was a weird era where first of all
there was a record mm-hmm that you were
on that got leaked with Eminem damn
yeah and then there was at a point in
time where you and I would talk and I
would I remember I gotten I
I got in trouble once like eight nine
years ago for playing one of your
records on a shade 45 you did I don't
know there was like I didn't know that
there was like a list on shade full moon
every list but like listen we'd be crazy
to say mmm isn't one of the jedis
Eminem's [ __ ] worth incredible I
would never say that but talk about that
the record that leaked I'm assuming you
know the record it was you Jeezy and em
yeah and it was uh I remember hearing it
on - dope boy shout to shake and MEK
but I remember loud to shake this is my
dawg but yeah that song never officially
came out
no and I from what I understand that was
like a big fuss geez II went on a
[ __ ] radio and said a man
Freddie Gibbs [ __ ] up my relationship
with every new he said that but you
didn't exactly the song came out like it
wasn't like you leaked it
I never met a man in my life why were
you I know why I never met Eminem in my
[ __ ] life I never met the [ __ ] ever
and I was four I think
I think it's 2006 I was probably science
engineer you know I'm saying exactly
yeah but I never met a man in my [ __ ]
life I met em renamed it the what's that
uh what's that [ __ ] dangerous values or
bad value what's the name in a store
today I was you know some of you knows
I'm Tori I'm seeing him for 15 seconds
you know I'm saying so name it
never met the [ __ ] so I don't know I I
know Paul Ron Paul Rosenberg your
manager is a Jewish man of course and
John Paul's burden wasn't there an
interview or something where you had
said something that you that that that
they might have to like Paul or somebody
from come on Bullock if we're going back
to like 2000 every interview I do I'll
say something that somebody's gonna
[ __ ] you mad it you know I mean right
time both your managers were Jewish all
my managers are Jewish of all time you
know me anyway I only recall having one
manager and that's Lambeau so like
everybody else was just like helpers you
know I'm saying like you're your helper
but I only have one manager of my whole
career and that's Ben Benjamin Lambert
that's only a man that's the only only
manager that I hit on my whole career
everybody else was just like a helper
you know well listen let's talk about
the new [ __ ] um you helped her [ __ ]
Jesus Christ by the way we you and I
have talked in a system anyway
you say you're about 60% middle amber
big big the Lambo you're saying about
60% down with your new [ __ ] yep
so we can we just dropped alfredo
bike-to-bike to bite your new really
backed about the but really piñatas
listen bro no shadow of a doubt Loki's
will not keep its key price Freddie real
no respect and I just chopped it up with
his name you know I'm saying but yeah
and you know I mean we bout to do a
record and I mean so I [ __ ] with him
heavy but if Meek Mill would have made
you want to live twice honey here which
we're looking at a different way I
wouldn't have me I'm asking you the game
would be game of course cuz he won't
popular anymore of course but like me
him talk this week I said Bravo would
you salute I salute that [ __ ] all time
so you and meek spoke this week about
yes sir because that's all about do a
record so you guys talk about working
together yes sir what he one of the guys
that I look up and I look at in the game
and I'd be late for show you know I mean
for salute you I mean [ __ ] man
sodomy me a [ __ ] meme you know was
there a point in time where like never
you just always were like yo man like I
feel like Meeks I never knew I never
knew bro so should there's a [ __ ]
around personally you know I can't
really say that I had a real beef with
you you know man like you know I see a
lot of [ __ ] like a lot of these weird
ass [ __ ] be talking about I'll just
like right now especially during this
time everybody's like black lives matter
and all this [ __ ] like that and I be
seeing [ __ ] that and it's my personal
experience but she you know I'm saying I
seen any good talk about black lives
matter but you try to kill me
Wow so the black lives matter when a
police kill us or do black last matter
all the time Wow and I said that [ __ ]
like six seven years ago and it was like
oh shut the [ __ ] up
and I get it but let's keep it real
I'm all about black progression totally
of course of course of course I want to
see my son get to the best of course you
know I'm like I got to tell my own
personal truth you know that hmm and
it's not giving them a pass time none of
that cuz I'm supporting them that I
don't support white supremacy or anybody
over or none of that shouts you know I
mean what okay Bruce you ain't no white
guy from the suburbs ever try to kill me
ain't no white guy from the suburbs ever
try to steal my [ __ ] it's been [ __ ]
sohail [ __ ] yeah we need to go
against white supremacy he'll [ __ ]
yeah we need to go against some of the
[ __ ] trying to oppress us yeah
but [ __ ] we need to get our [ __ ]
together
within in turn igger
we need to get our [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] together between [ __ ] and I don't
give a [ __ ] about no [ __ ] talkin about
no black lives matter none of that [ __ ]
cuz they do they matter all the time
you gonna talk about some BLM say that
[ __ ] all the time say that [ __ ] with my
cousin get killed my cousin got killed
by a [ __ ] my [ __ ] from a rival game so
that lost don't mean nothing to me
they lost didn't mean something to me
because the police didn't kill them by
the way your father was a cop exactly
people don't know that your dad was a
cop exactly yeah I know you definitely
what I have talked about that okay yeah
and when I was [ __ ] between a
is a [ __ ] three to ten or eight
I will worry about that [ __ ] worried
about him coming home let me worry about
him getting killed by somebody Fred let
me ask you now that like I said that
doesn't dispel the [ __ ] that cops do
you know I'm saying because like my pops
was a cop during the era where cops was
making [ __ ] nineteen thousand
dollars a year you know I'm saying Gary
in the end I will show you like science
you know and so like it is what it is
but at the same time you know they
[ __ ] just you know trying to [ __ ]
feed his [ __ ] family and it's a lot of
[ __ ] cops that get jobs they're
just trying to feed they [ __ ] family
and they fall a victim to [ __ ]
white supremacy within the [ __ ]
Department you know me the union's now
stop it don't think that cuz I'm with
the ACAB [ __ ] you know I'm saying all
[ __ ] is a bad type [ __ ] you
know I'm saying and you know I don't you
know I'm not an advocate of police
policing period you know then because
really I think policing is like slave
[ __ ] you know I'm saying I think it's
like definitely it comes from runaway
slaves it's a debate to be had was you
know Minneapolis really y'all [ __ ]
shouldn't have police to me period you
know I mean because it's always gonna be
a [ __ ] that's gonna need a job I mean
my dad was the [ __ ] that needed a job
and what the [ __ ] 1982 you know and
you're somebody to also who I mean
anyone who's ever been to a Freddie
Gibbs show knows the one thing you
always chant on stage is [ __ ] police
[ __ ] them
you know they're a [ __ ] 2000
and or was that 2005-2006
I mean no I I mean even my different you
know then the recipe Scannell mayi he
got murdered by the police now the first
thing I ever seen murder by the police
was Cannell me this was Gary Indiana
correct guy was the first [ __ ] that I
ever witnessed personally getting
murdered about it by police was Canal
McGee so
you know I know we give it up to a lot
of names there's a lot of famous names
that's rumored about police but let's
think about before social media there
was a lot more exactly but before social
media is a lot more it's a lot of guys
who name ain't and I love George Floyd
to know me recipes George Florida but
it's a lot of guys who ain't who name
and his famous is George Floyd
chance crusher you know saying Cannell
McGee you know I mean like my friend got
killed by the police and his death got
blamed on him having a somatic condition
so when I seen the tortilla the George
Floyd thing with the [ __ ]
aronia [ __ ] I was like bro get the
[ __ ] out here we saw the video like this
you can say [ __ ] and this was 10 12
years ago yeah you know I'm saying I'm
saying like all its cause the death was
ruled because he had a somatic condition
but like you know his family seen people
that the police choked him out with a
nice dick they choked him to death same
thing is George fully dog just thinking
I mean he wasn't camera phones let's be
real
no mean it was no camera phones there
that was it was no way to really track
that as it is now you know me the world
wasn't as social media intensive at that
point you know I mean yeah
so there was nobody outside with a
[ __ ] camera phone this was like I
said this is like 2005 you know me or
maybe later maybe I'm wrong you know I
mean yeah but but it was in the era of
not having a camera phone that's what
I'm saying and you know Canaille McGee
got murdered about a [ __ ] Gary police
department I just think that in general
like the conversation of like you just
said do we need police I think that
there needs to be some sort of you know
if if something happens where you know
someone gets raped or someone gets
murdered like there's got like we got to
figure that part out but in the
as far as what most police calls come
from stupid petty [ __ ] that in general
can just be handled amongst like civis
like like like there's no reason why if
someone tries to shoplift something from
a 7-eleven right are you oh just put it
back and keep them keep it moving van
there's no reason to call me you know
what I'm saying like you stole some [ __ ]
I I just don't know where the because
right now obviously many apples I they
cut off your hand I think well in
Minneapolis about [ __ ] hands off and
it won't need police if you be like yo
[ __ ] if you steal something you
couldn't your hand off us guaranteed
[ __ ] won't steal your in your knee no
police force you might be right place
they only in police force I don't like
if you rape we're cutting off your dick
you know if so I just feel like if you
rape somebody you need your dick cut off
in general let me put that on a record
if you wreck somebody [ __ ] you need
your [ __ ] dick cut
no [ __ ] we should not be a PC no
attention pop let me tell you a real
story okay a real story about a
bitch-ass [ __ ] okay you know I'm saying
so I was different to this next to this
[ __ ] ass [ __ ] that I didn't know I
didn't even know you know me a [ __ ]
a rapist of a [ __ ] okay you know saying
a [ __ ] pedophile fake-ass [ __ ]
[ __ ] ass rapist ass [ __ ] nothing hmm
so one night I'll Drive a home can Erica
can attest to distort any mom of course
the mother of my child shot there but
anyway shall the eye reality I read but
anyway so bro I'm coming home just
probably like I don't know mm I don't
know 18s I don't know I don't know I
don't remember but I don't remember the
year but it was recently so I'm coming
home and Erica called me and she like oh
the
face here for you and I'm saying like I
don't know like you know so I'm thinking
like all down its drove charge or
something like that
right I just got off the dole [ __ ]
ass [ __ ] in your yeah so I'm like okay
they couldn't get me on that
so now they trying to trust the FBI
about the [ __ ] get me on some
drugs [ __ ] Oh some or whatever murder I
don't know who knows right now exam so
I'm like all right so she called me when
I'm on you know I mean we we live in are
we living like and senile some [ __ ] she
I'm like on like venture she called me
when I wanted sure and I'm like [ __ ]
then I get to the street that we lived
on and I'll see the blue and red lights
and I'm like damn I'm about to go to
prison you know I'm saying like I don't
want to go down that Street I was like
you know what should I like I got to a
point I was I shot dip right now almost
like that scene in belly correct I was
like should I dip right now or should I
go down there and do you think about
hurry
deal with it your daughter my dog still
I was like my daughter was like one and
a half right
somebody bro I want to see my daughter
you know I'm saying so you went it dealt
with it I said [ __ ] it I'm gonna go deal
with it you know I mean whatever it is
you know I had some homies in jail that
I was like snitched on me you know so I
was thinking like of the whole time I
get in there I'm expecting the worst so
I might you know what [ __ ] it I gotta go
to my baby my baby down there it's
police down there her mom calling me the
police in the house I get down there I'm
coming from the studio it's like 2:30
a.m. and I mean I got like I probably
got three guns on me dog listen I've
been in your Cadillac before shower to
the Van Nuys cream so I got guns on me
and everything died so I'm like yo so I
pulled up I see the police van what's
the face I'm saying the van all that I
[ __ ] so I just like
man I take all the guns out of the gun
out the glove box the gun from under my
seat and they're gonna hit on me
I had them all on my hand I said bro
look here we go I get out of the car
get on the ground I say here here guns
cuz I want to get shot by the police now
here go all three guns here go me I'm
surrendering you know I'm saying don't
hurt my daughter her mother eight
I like ten SWAT [ __ ] come over there
SWAT team [ __ ] come over there put the
guns on me and they say oh won't good
[ __ ] about you we ain't look for you but
your neighbor pedophile she doing
internet porn and then I look up cuz if
it's for me it would have been the
[ __ ] DEA and FBI so I'm looking
at all these [ __ ] jackets and I'll see
no DEA all I see is like some i I
something I not ice but some others
combustion yeah I'm like what is these
throw SWAT seems like get up [ __ ] the
SWAT team wanted the [ __ ] was black he
say hey man take them get them guns in
the house first of all they're good but
we not here for you he said we're here
for this [ __ ] next door your next-door
neighbor's I'm mother [ __ ] pedophile
rapist wow did you you had no idea I
have no [ __ ] idea you know I'm saying
but I thought the SWAT team what step
for me you're like it was over no I'm
saying I'm by rows over I'm gonna turn
myself in rap career over everything I
said look this is post [ __ ] rape
charge in your post of it exactly so I'm
like I all the [ __ ] that I had on me I'm
giving it up right now like I had three
illegal guns on me they said bro take
your take your black asses
what do you let me add you some bro what
[ __ ] you're the realest [ __ ] I
have in hip-hop and that I've
encountered as a human being yes sir
what what do you make of like this whole
entire Takashi thing man
um because Akon is doing it locked up
remix what I'm like I'm just wondering
what your perspective is like I know
what it is
I know what your perspective is but it
same time like I feel like it's before
too long we're gonna see certain rappers
doing records with them like I feel like
de Tori features inevitable I feel like
it's inevitable it's gonna happen
cuz I know that those guys were like
actual friends before all this happened
yeah you know I mean you know fake
[ __ ] always link and you guys did
Mexico together so what the [ __ ] that
means
how about I'm saying is like I said fake
[ __ ] always link what are your
thoughts on the whole situation because
I do think that there's two separate
conversations there's the entertainment
conversation and then there's the you
know the real street conversation
factual I mean you know you name
somebody that probably would do a song
with him I would you know if I was to
think about 10 [ __ ] that wouldn't do a
song Takashi's that I was at yeah Tory
would be one of them but uh you know
what man I don't hold [ __ ] like that
do the same standard as you hold
yourself to not at all or people who
realize are x9 and Tory like the young
[ __ ] like that I don't even hold them
[ __ ] to light Street near the
standards because then [ __ ] ain't
Street [ __ ] you know then like a con I
love a con shout the boo
but no I don't respect that move of
course not mother [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] I mother you know that I mean
constant records like it's like even if
there's convict records or whatever I
don't give a [ __ ] what it is but you
know my perspective is I you know I
don't respect that move you know I mean
and like you know she and you know me
and Buddha's a dinner together not too
long ago and they had [ __ ]
Delilah's but I love a fam I love a con
but no no okay and I might make a move
and I might make a move that you don't
respect but that don't mean that when
you see me that is beef know exactly I
don't respect that move not a nothing
no [ __ ] way you know I mean so it is
what it is but you you do you think
y'all [ __ ] richer than me so whatever
y'all doing you know I mean like is some
rich [ __ ] [ __ ] so I'm not knocking
y'all you think anybody who works with
that guy there's just like a stain on
okay say that because because like you
said you the standards are all different
frontal Oh every [ __ ] to the same
senators me cuz every make like a little
dinky does the song with six nine you be
like yeah whatever it's little Dickie
like you know but if it's it but if it's
[ __ ] meek it Meeks not doing it
wouldn't do that
no of course not but I'm saying like as
far as standards it's like there's
certain there's certain artists there
you'd be like I do what you do
everything I might do what you do cuz I
don't hold every auto hold none of these
[ __ ] to the same senators me you know
and I had to learn that personally
because that first I used to do that I
our sites to be like man what the [ __ ]
you [ __ ] Oh what the [ __ ]
by the way I know I'd be like ah you
know I mean it'll me unless you like do
some like I'll do a song with them there
any [ __ ] to you know I mean like let's
you do like some like six nine [ __ ] or
some are Kelly [ __ ] then I won't [ __ ]
for the lines in the same yeah exactly
that's it like I said I will do a song
with six nine and I won't do a song we
are Kelly right now Frey bills 96 Kelly
what and remain tails what our shake
I'll go to Gary [ __ ]
what Chicago Gary he's your figures good
best of all worlds [ __ ] but now best
above [ __ ] but now kills a big I got a
plate [ __ ] you dude let me ask you this
at a certain point in time there was a
stigma attached to your name within the
industry uh-huh and for me it was always
like you know fred is just too real for
this [ __ ] like like when we talk about
keeping it real like Fran has kept it
real throughout his whole career despite
how it may or may not affect his career
right on the other end you're also one
of the I mean one of the biggest
[ __ ] in rap to other rappers think
so yeah maybe I think you might have
cleaned that up over the last few years
but do you were you like a where of that
stigma that it was attached to the name
Freddie Gibbs in hip hop because I ought
to deal with it all the time because I
was always a Freddie good guy
Oh yo what's up with your man's no man
like what you want for being late maybe
like what's up with your baby bro role
if you feel that imagine how that will
feel that's why you get paid the big
bucks you got a deal with a lot of [ __ ]
bad you know baby baby it was up to me
you know I mean but like you know a lot
of needs to be like yo sup [ __ ] man but
they they not gonna do nothing you know
I mean like you know I'll you know I
said I probably said a lot nigga's name
in this interview you've said a lot of
people's names in many interviews many
nobody listen everybody's always gonna
like talk and talk it out and be like yo
bro you know I didn't really like this
I'd be like well my stance is always
this man so it is what it is you know
I'm saying so I love all y'all [ __ ]
they're rapping all that [ __ ] you know
me but you know I'm not you know I'm not
really scared of y'all [ __ ] man my
philosophy is this man you you give love
and you get it back so I give love to
everybody you know I'm saying cuz like a
[ __ ] don't want like these hands like
these bullets and [ __ ] like that [ __ ]
want to rap [ __ ] wanna do shows [ __ ]
wanna like get money in a rap game and
like be able to move around and [ __ ]
with no [ __ ] pressure or no
problem
so keep doing it mean you have spoke
about this like your money at all times
I would love to hear wanna play with me
how nobody this guys take a shot well
I'm not the one to be play with cuz you
got a gold please you gotta go places
you gotta go to LA you gotta go to New
York you know I'm saying you gotta go to
ATL you got one of Miami and this gives
me a tour in places oh my god I mean I'm
saying I'll walk up to your
[ __ ] dinner table name is and
[ __ ] know that I've done that before
with them and they bitching I believe
you all right are you all right Fred are
you okay [ __ ] Fred
black lives matter [ __ ] so any [ __ ]
that's black and got some rap [ __ ] going
on you matter Nick okay doubt you want
well ain't none of you [ __ ] gonna
fight
or play or rap well against the Gibbs Oh
my mama and that's on my mama that's all
my son that's on my daughter [ __ ] Fred
I can concur with you on the rapping
thing I could occur with all this well
listen all I have to say is Fred now
they give Alfredo's out a phrase poured
out in a night to be [ __ ] with foo got
a better album out right now hey we ever
get some more Pusha T records cuz I do
feel like nobody's rapped about selling
dope better than us all right here I got
brand new [ __ ] song right here which
one here that boy just called me I got a
brand new [ __ ] song oh [ __ ]
yeah barrel Christie's all right here I
got records I thought you were gonna
play weird
yo labels gonna kill me level will kill
both of us Fred yo look Alfredo's out
Alfredo's out and I hate to be [ __ ]
with back-to-back albums of the year
shout-out to alchemy back to back to
back
we don't 3p we're not doing Isaiah we
know you can order is the new album
gonna come out before 2021 didn't it's a
3-piece only what we do we look Mike and
feel me LM how many records in are you
on the new album 20 and this is
production from ad-lib an al man live
alchemist shot the [ __ ] 30 rock
set off the [ __ ] a P and B rock
you told me you got a PB wait you told
me you got a little baby record
hey self a little baby son we got we
just can't skip over this you and little
baby got a record done well I'm talking
about so my [ __ ] Rashad that's all I'm
saying I didn't mean to leak that
information out so Rashad little baby
Freddie Gibbs coming to me and shout out
the [ __ ] Norv a shout out it's
an Aaron Bishop and on the aim like boom
gangster get out the Lambo chance a
Lambo the legend at all time Lambo to
live in a shot a Lambo you know me it's
night he's gonna hate this interview but
it's all good cuz you know it's the boob
I can talk about a Lambo what's my dog
right what you gonna do about it you
can't do about it
I hate come on over here to [ __ ] a
bootleg care to get my [ __ ] off by the
way if you want to check out awesome
vintage video games [ __ ] just go to
Lambos page go to Lambo pay
cuz Lambo dough's does not have a ps4
he's got a [ __ ] yes SNES he got a
Nintendo and Atari you know I'm saying
so he got all that old [ __ ] and she is
still working channel to Kevin Durant
shelter KD that's my dog how the KB
shelter rich I'm about to pick up rich
brains I'm a rich climbing shoutout so
that's Auto riches and auto written is
Fred I gotta piss gotta piss - did you
finish your shot cuz I finish mine
that's how we ended the interview
gangster Gibbs man alfredo I'll now go
get it [ __ ] with it